alex has a physical body break and a
spiritual
emotional break where all of these
shackles come down tell me what's in the
book maggie
you don't like me you've never liked me
that's not true
[Music]
which part
that i've never liked you marsha gay is
absolutely incredible these two women
laid it all out and it was this power
that maggie brenner had over alex this
little bit of power that could in fact
destroy her career alex is just trying
to survive
desperately it's a little late to be
storming into my hotel room now what
what is it you even want marsha feels so
bad being so mean to me we both end a
scene where we're not nice to each other
we say i'm so sorry my interest isn't
trying to do right by your daughter
they're gonna try to make it seem like
she had problems long before she got to
uba what kind of problems
cory's wrestling with protecting hannah
protecting the name of a victim who
can't speak for herself and with the
specter of fred hanging over him saying
i'm going to out you at any point which
if it was uncovered it would be a
problem for his relationship with
bradley that fact that corey is able to
navigate that in some way
is i think quite interesting billy is so
good this season
he's in this position of power he has
all these feelings about bradley they're
so complicated there's so much at stake
billy is one of the most fascinating
minds alive and
brings
things to this character that just
i mean you watch every take and you're
just in awe of what comes out of him i
don't blink when he is acting
i didn't want to be this person
i didn't want to hurt anyone
i didn't want people to think i was the
kind of person that could hurt someone
in that scene steve carell just moved
everybody on set and i think it's really
a testament to how incredible an actor
he is
there's a wonderful dynamic between
mitch and paolo because she was not a
part of his previous world he feels like
he can probably speak in a more
unfettered pure way with her so she's a
wonderful vessel for us to see what
exactly is mitch purely thinking mitch
realizes that he did terrible things and
that there were real consequences for
his actions and that he really hurt
people paolo asks him the questions that
he's asking himself on the inside and
she's forcing him to confront these
issues and answer those questions i'm
just pretty damaged
i know
you